bonsoir Tamara on va bien entendu parler
de ces trois coups lauréats du prix
Nobel de la paix mais d'abord parlons
spécifiquement de mémorial cette ONG qui
d'ailleurs subit ces bureaux ont été
visités sur la visée des services de
sécurité ont été saisis
le droit de leur saisir et d'en faire
une propriété du gouvernement russe ça
ça a été annoncé par la Cour parce qu'il
comparaissait ils sont en guerre avec le
gouvernement depuis des années la Cour
avait déjà décidé la course suprême en
Russie de dissoudre
cette organisation qui qui est un pilier
je vous dirais de la démocratie en
Russie en fait ce qu'elle était depuis
la fin de l'URSS et donc elle est statut
aujourd'hui que ça y est on va aussi
saisir leur bureau et leur bureau le
siège social c'est souvent pour faire
des entrevues mais aussi un an à peine
pour faire un reportage sur ce qu'elle
représente organisation et puis vous
savez c'est emblématique tout le monde
connaît cette adresse là à Moscou parce
que ça héberge entre autres des tonnes
et des tonnes d'archives sur toutes les
atrocités commises par le régime de
Staline c'était ça la raison d'être au
départ de mémorial documenter les crimes
du régime stalinien il y a aussi la plus
grande collection d'objets du Goulag
c'est très impressionnant à visiter un
des écoles qui vont qui allait parce que
c'est c'est plus permis mais qui allait
visiter ce qui est considérait un peu un
musée donc ça ça a été saisi ça va être
saisi mais on a ordonné ça en cours
aujourd'hui et c'est arrivé ce jugement
de la Cour quelques heures après que
mémorial se soit vu décerner le Prix
Nobel
pour tout ce qu'elle représente vous
savez et c'est pour ça que la lutte pour
la vérité la lutte contre la répression
encore dans cette Russie moderne et
c'est pour ça qu'elle se partage
aujourd'hui c'est là qu'on va revenir
aux autres coloréens
je pense qu'on a voulu du côté je peux
pas lire dans les pensées du comité
Nobel mais je pense qu'ils l'ont très
clairement indiqué en disant aujourd'hui
on choisit des pays qui qui représentent
la paix je pense qu'on les noements en
Normands des représentants de la Russie
de l'Ukraine et du Bélarus je pense
qu'il y a une reconnaissance là-dedans
que la plus grande menace à ce que le
prix représente la paix en 2022 c'est le
régime de Vladimir Poutine et qui qui
travaille met dans la main avec le cash
and Co parce que oui les deux autres
coloriastes importants de les mentionner
il y a un prisonnier politique au
Bélarus qui a fait de la prison comme
vous l'avez vu dans le reportage de Lise
de Lise à l'aise bialysky qui a fait de
la prison qui en était ressorti en 2014
mais qui a été recondaminé une fois de
plus il y a deux ans quand il y a eu des
soulèvements populaires à porte
important contre Lucas and Co qu'on
accuse d'être un dictateur mais qui
aurait volé aussi l'élection la dernière
le dirigeant du Bélarus et le troisième
lauréat c'est ce centre des libertés de
l'Ukraine qui a été fondée en 2017 qu'on
connaissait pas beaucoup si on
s'intéresse pas particulièrement à son
travail mais qui est devenu essentiel
depuis le début de la guerre parce que
c'est ce gros plat qui va sur le terrain
une tâche absolument épouvantable qui
doit documenter les crimes de guerre
soupçonnées dans sur le terrain et la
commise par l'armée russe depuis le
début de la gare et dites-nous un Tamara
comment s'est reçu par l'Ukraine en
général parce que instinctivement on
pourrait croire que on s'en réjouit mais
c'est pas nécessairement le cas mais je
pense que ce gros place en réjouit ça
c'est sûr et on entendait j'écoutais des
entrevues de la directrice qui disait
bah c'est pour nous c'est une
reconnaissance
mais le gouvernement ukrainien
des conseillers clés de valise qui dit
puis je vais juste il dit vous savez le
Nobel une drôle de définition de ce que
c'est une drôle de compréhension de ce
que c'est la paix si des représentants
de deux pays la Russie Hilbert la Russe
qui qui agresse un troisième pays sont
nommés dans ce prix donc c'est sûr que
tu sais on aurait pu nommer zelens qui
il était en liste on a c'est un nom qui
qui était revenu dans il pressenti pour
comme parce qu'on l'a déjà fait donner
Barack Obama et à d'autres chefs de
gouvernement et détend le déjà fait ça
Mireille
mémorial soit du temps passant mais je
pense pas que je pense qu'il y a
certainement cette conviction que
l'Ukraine pourrait aurait pu même si
c'est que cette organisme là mérité son
Obel seul mais c'est sûr que ce qu'on
reproche au comité du prix Nobel c'est
de confondre la raison d'être de ces
trois organismes c'est à dire que les
prisonniers politiques au Bélarus se
battent contre une dictature les Russes
se battent contre une ce qu'on appelle
aussi une dictature de plus en plus une
autocratie celle de Vladimir Poutine les
Ukrainiens sont un peuple
qui agressait par une guerre qui vivent
dans une démocratie donc c'est cette le
fait qu'on confond peut-être le mandat
de ces organismes qui qui froissent mais
je vous laisse écouter vous êtes la
nature
la présidente qu'on dit élu du Belarus
mais qui est en exil elle explique
pourquoi c'est important ce trio de les
mettre ensemble dans le Prix Nobel de la
paix
de frienda stromy crime and drus
de Fight agent
Poutine is the fight for the MOOC
freedom in Beatles
voilà qui est intéressant mais somme
toute on le voit on cible et on veut
récompenser des organismes et des
personnes liées à la société civile
c'est ça qu'il faut souligner ça aussi
c'est intéressant on aurait pu choisir
des politiciens mais le fait qu'on
choisit des gens des acteurs de la
société civile c'est aussi ce message
comme on le fait qu'on choisit des
journalistes que le vecteur de
changement est de paix c'est pas
seulement les gouvernements en fait
c'est surtout la société civile merci
beaucoup au revoir